en el vídeo pasado vimos como dos
compañías que forman un duopolio si
estas dos compañías se coordinan pueden
formar un monopolio y pueden optimizar
sus beneficios económicos colectivos
vimos que producían 50 unidades por
periodo y los repartían asumiendo que
eran de idénticas cada una produciendo
la mitad ahora bien recordemos que en el
vídeo pasado eran 250 unidades por
compañía pero después vimos que había un
incentivo para hacer trampa que
produciendo unidades extra desde el
punto de vista del mercado el beneficio
económico marginal en esas unidades
incrementadas será negativo y de esa
manera todo el beneficio económico se
bajaría un poco mientras produces más
unidades pero la compañía tramposa
obtenía una mayor cantidad de esas
unidades una mayor cantidad de ese
beneficio económico entonces la compañía
tramposa ella va de 250 por periodo a
280 y todo esto gracias a la compañía
que decidió no hacer trampa esta
perdería obviamente más de lo que gano y
bueno obviamente ahora la compañía no
tramposa
y tendrás ganas de ser tramposa de hacer
trampa y entonces ambas se irán
incrementando la producción así que
ambas compañías ahora tienen el
incentivo de seguir así incrementando no
respetando su acuerdo y bueno esto va a
seguir así y va a seguir así hasta que
llegas a una cantidad a una cantidad
donde ya no queda beneficio económico
alguno justo como aquí yo lo dibuje la
curva de demanda intersecta a la curva
de costo total promedio ya no hay
beneficio económico ya no queda estamos
produciendo una nueva cantidad parecen
ser 75 unidades más o menos 75 unidades
para todo el mercado pero en este caso
el precio del mercado es igual al costo
total promedio como puedes ver así que
no hay no hay beneficio económico por
unidad en promedio no lo hay ahora bien
yo quiero pensar en esto de una manera
de teoría de juegos así que veamos acá
abajo tengo un montón de estados éste es
el estado óptimo el cual en el que vamos
a empezar aquí el cual podemos llamar
estado óptimo de pareto es llamado así
por bill fred o pareto sociólogo
economista
italiano y lo que nos dice lo siguiente
que ese es el estado y no hay otro
estado donde pueda haber mejoras para
alguien sin perjudicar a otro individuo
aquí tenemos estados ahí estados donde
el azul está en mejor estado entonces
por ejemplo en este estado el azul está
mejor pero el verde está peor y por eso
se llama optimal y that de pareto ahora
bien compañeros lo que yo quiero hacer
en este vídeo es ver cómo éstos irán
cambiando su estado dado a los
incentivos después también hablaremos
del equilibrio de nash y acá en este eje
vamos a suponer que aquí aquí hay un eje
digamos que aquí está a es una de las
compañías y aquí está donde producen 25
digamos que en la cantidad tramposa de
75 y bueno de hecho cabe mencionar que
en el mercado ese es en efecto la
cantidad de equilibrio si esto fuera una
perfecta competencia ellos producirían
la mitad de eso 37.5 unidades y mientras
vamos de 25 hasta llegar a 37.5 unidades
nos indica que se hace más trampa
entonces aquí yo pongo más
y bueno acá no hay trampas podríamos
hacer lo mismo por el verde la compañía
que representa el verde lo voy a nombrar
de aquellos producen 25 y acá producen
37.5 y mientras vamos hacia arriba se
hace más trampa entonces aquí ya también
pongo más trampa para pensarlo de un
modo de teoría de juegos aquí tenemos el
estado óptimo de pareto y es óptimo en
muchas maneras se maximiza el beneficio
económico total aquí no existe un estado
en el cual alguien se beneficie sin
perjudicar a alguien más ahora también
hay que pensar si esto es un equilibrio
de nash y bueno primero hay que recordar
que es un equilibrio de nh el equilibrio
de nash aquí aquí lo pongo es un estado
es un estado donde dejando los otros
miembros constantes dejando a los otros
miembros constantes bueno en este caso
tenemos a dos compañías así que una se
deja constante dejando a los otros
constantes un participante no puede
ganar cambiando de estrategia así que yo
pongo aquí un jugador no puede ganar
cambiando de estrategia
el jugador no puede ganar cambiando de
estrategia así que bueno ya con esta
definición hay que pensar si esto si
esto se cumple si eso es verdad en este
estado de aquí bueno pues hay que dejar
a uno constante supongamos que ya
dejamos constante así que nos enfocamos
en esta columna de aquí ahora bien hay
algo que me puede hacer que le permita
ganar un cambio de estrategia que le
pueda hacer claro él puede incrementar
su producción así que iríamos de este
estado a uno hacia arriba ahora de esta
en 280 es su beneficio económico
mientras que a solamente tiene 200 como
puedes ver ve sale ganando entonces ahí
no hubo equilibrio de nash aunque si lo
hay o sea si existe si hay un
participante que pueda ganar cambiando
su estrategia hay que repasar la
definición de equilibrio de nash para
estar más claros en esto es un estado
donde dejando a otros constantes no hay
jugado bueno aquí pongo no hay jugador
que no pueda ganar cambiando de
estrategia
acabamos de mostrar que al menos hay un
participante que si puede ganar
cambiando de estrategia y dejando los
otros constantes ahora
dejamos saber constante en 25 a puede
ganar cambiando su estrategia puede irse
hasta hacia este lado entonces esto no
es un equilibrio de nash luego sin tener
en cuenta el estado al que vayamos si
vamos a este estado aún así no será un
equilibrio de nash si dejamos a
constante después de mejorar
incrementando su producción o si dejamos
saber constante entonces aún puede tener
mejora haciendo más trampa así que
ninguno de estos es un equilibrio de nh
en cualquiera de estos y dejamos a
constante ve puede producir más o si
dejamos saber constante puede producir
más esto en cualquiera de estos estados
pasa obtienen benefícios aquí a va de
130 a 160 obteniendo ganancia y va a
seguir ocurriendo esto siguen
produciendo más y más y más como puedes
ver vamos de aquí para acá luego de acá
para acá luego acá quizás hace más
trampa luego ve hace más trampa luego
hace un poquito más de trampa luego ve
un poquito más el beneficio económico se
suma de ahí debe se va haciendo más y
más pequeño hasta que finalmente hace un
poco más de trampa y bueno
pero en beneficio económico hasta llegar
aquí a cero ahora hay que pensar si esto
es un equilibrio de nancy obviamente no
van a querer retroceder si dejas a
constante ve no va a querer bajarse
porque perdería beneficio económico
si dejas haber constante a no va a
querer moverse a la derecha porque bueno
eso no les funciona entonces ve no
quiere bajar ni a quiere ir hacia la
derecha y bueno quizás ahora tú te tú te
preguntas okey bueno espera espera que
qué sucede si producen arriba de los
37.5 muy muy buena observación muy buena
pregunta pues vamos a ver bueno pues
dejando a constante y que ve fuera
produciendo más de los 37.5 desde este
estado entonces todo se va a volver todo
va a ser negativo de ahí en adelante
todo va a ser negativo serán números
negativos y lo puedes ver acá arriba si
se incrementa la cantidad más allá de la
cantidad de mercado 75 37.5 cada uno el
precio en el que estarían vendiendo es
menor que el costo total promedio así
que el beneficio económico promedio por
será negativo por ende habrá un total de
beneficio económico negativo como lo
puedes tú ver aquí y ninguna de estas
dos compañías va a querer producir más
desde este estado de aquí no les
conviene y bueno aún de repente en este
estado dejando a los otros constantes
si dejas a constante ve no puede ganar
cambiando de estrategia si dejas haber
constante entonces no podrá ganar
cambiando de estrategia entonces aquí
arriba si estamos en un equilibrio de
nash lo voy a escribir equilibrio de
nash aquí si si cumple aquí no fue el
estado óptimo el óptimo el estado óptimo
está justamente aquí pero como ambos
quisieron hacer trampa como ambos
rompieron los acuerdos pudieron terminar
en este estado de acá en ceros aunque
este estado es estable no existe algo
que dejando al otro fijo no hay algo que
puedan hacer para optimizar lo que
pueden hacer aunque no aplican as podrán
decir ok
hemos estado arruinando nuestros
negocios
hay que coordinar otra vez yo me
comprometo a bajar mi producción si tú
bajas
y amigos otra vez luego pueden intentar
llegar a este estado otra vez no estamos
dejando aquí a los otros constantes no
lo que se está diciendo es yo cambio mi
estrategia si tú cambias tu estrategia
así que quizás solamente que ibas de
otro acuerdo pero no significa que esto
no sea un equilibrio de nash esto es un
equilibrio de nash
si dejas a otro jugador constante el
otro jugador no puede cambiar su
estrategia para ganar